la propagación de la variante delta no
se detiene la creciente amenaza del
virus ha enfocado a la preocupación en
los no vacunados principalmente los
jóvenes del está es más peligrosa y
doblemente contagiosa según expertos y
ha despertado la alerta en varios países
llevando algunos a retomar restricciones
la propagación de delta ha estado
acompañada de un aumento de las muertes
en eeuu principalmente entre las
personas inoculadas como advierten las
autoridades de washington hay un mensaje
claro que está llegando esto se está
convirtiendo en una pandemia de los no
vacunados y andrés neira we are sing
estamos viendo brotes de casos en partes
del país que tienen una baja cobertura
de vacunación porque las personas no
vacunadas están en riesgo y las
comunidades que están totalmente
vacunadas están generalmente greenway la
preocupación también está en europa que
puso en alerta a los estados tras un
alza en las cifras de contagios los
líderes llamaron a sus ciudadanos a
vacunarse a medida que se re imponen
algunas restricciones como el toque de
queda nocturno en varias poblaciones de
españa y francia- o pruebas pcr para
viajeros internacionales de 24 horas de
antelación como lo ha pedido el país
galo a partir de este domingo según
advirtió la organización mundial de la
salud
aún quedan millones de personas sin
vacunar en la región de europa siendo
los jóvenes del grupo más amenazado en
américa latina' la variante se encuentra
en 14 países y supone un nuevo desafío
para los frágiles sistemas sanitarios
se espera que en agosto en países como
méjico al menos el 90 por ciento los
contagios sean por la variante